good morning my name is dr. Stacy
Schultz cherry and I'm in the department
of infectious diseases at st. Jude
Children's Research Hospital in Memphis
Tennessee and today I'm going to be
telling you about our work on enteric
viruses and how they cause diarrhea
now when you say the word diarrhea
everybody laughs there's stories there
are songs
there's poems there's even books like
everyone poops because a hundred percent
of the population will get diarrhea at
some point in their life in fact there's
a great statistic from the government
that there are 272 million cases per
year and you can break that down to
eight per second and if you want to put
this in context of how much diarrhea
that actually is if you think about it
in the US and say there's 12 point 7
million cases we know there's actually
double that and there's 200 million
cases internationally you can do
mathematical calculations based on the
number of episodes per day number of
days that the diary occurs and what you
end up with is that there's at least six
blow over Niagara Falls that would be
the equivalent of the amount of diarrhea
that happens worldwide every year now we
all laugh and we we sing the songs we
read the books but it's actually a
devastating cause of childhood mortality
especially in the developed world where
respiratory and enteric or diarrheal
diseases are the leading causes of death
and here in the u.s. nine percent of all
hospitalizations in children less than
that five years of age are due to
diarrhea and it's a significant problem
in the very young the immunocompromised
and the elderly populations and the
picture is of my son when he was little
and he
I ended up in pediatric intensive care
unit when he was in kindergarten for
what ended up being an enteric virus
where he was hospitalized for seven to
ten days and lost 20% of his body weight
due to diarrhea now my laboratory is
very interested in how viruses
associated with diarrhea actually cause
disease not just how do they cause
disease but how does the body fight them
how do they change and can we develop
better therapies for these viruses and
today we're gonna focus on one
particular virus and that is Astro virus
so a bit of background on Astro viruses
there positive-sense non-enveloped RNA
viruses and they're very small all this
means is that when you have the material
or the genetic components of the virus
and it can get into a cell it's
infectious all by itself and it's a
relatively new virus meaning it really
wasn't discovered until the late 1970s
and it got its name Astro virus for the
star shaped morphology it has when you
look at it under a high-powered
microscope and you can see some of the
images there in this star shape on the
surface of the virus now Astro viruses
even though many people haven't heard of
them they're a leading cause of disease
in humans mammals birds and even fish
very recently Astro viruses were found
to infect fish now although many of you
have never heard of it before
I can guarantee you you've all had it
and that 90% of you have antibodies to
it having been exposed probably as a
child we also know it's an emerging
problem meaning when people go out in
nature and they look for viruses what
they find are primarily viruses like
Coronas which are what causes MERS and
stars as well as Astro viruses
and for a long time people thought that
if you could only get human Astra virus
you couldn't get an Astra virus from a
cow or a cat or a dog and we're not sure
that's actually true and that these
viruses may be able to cause species
barriers and in fact humans or sonic the
other thing that's not quite true that
people always believed is that Astra
viruses only cause diarrhea that is
absolutely not the case in fact disease
can range from asymptomatic meaning you
don't even know that you have it but yet
you're shutting it to causing mild to
severe diarrhea it can cause respiratory
disease and primarily an immuno
compromised people it can go outside of
the intestine and actually infect your
brain and cause what can be a fatal
encephalitis so here are some facts
about Astra virus where do you get them
and how do you know if you have it well
you know you have it you'll end up with
a headache some nausea diarrhea usually
for one or two days after you've been
exposed very very infectious virus very
difficult to get rid of in the
environment your risk groups are people
more likely to have severe disease our
children under the age of two your
premature infants again
immunocompromised people where that
virus can get out of the intestine and
cause disease at other sites and the
elderly typically you get this in the
winter and it's known as a winter
diarrhea and again everybody will get
this virus so where are you going to get
them how are you gonna be exposed to it
well they're everywhere they are in the
food they're in water so they are food
and water borne viruses you can get them
from infected people in the hospital and
here's the problem is that many people
will have a strobe eye
and they won't know it and they'll
continue to shag the virus into the
environment where other people can get
infected they're very stable so for
those of you using your Purell to clean
your hands that will not inactivate an
Astra virus really need to wash your
hands with soap and water and you can
use special disinfectants in order to
get rid of it if you do know you've been
infected and it's in your bathroom or in
your hospital now one of the issues with
Astra viruses is that they're
underreported what do I mean by that
what I mean is most of the time somebody
gets Astro virus they may not go to the
doctor so we don't really know the true
incidence of infection there's another
problem with diagnosing these viruses
and that our current diagnostic tests
only recognize one form or one group of
[Music]
astrobiologists
here at st. Jude we've developed a
diagnostic test that will detect all
human Astro virus forms that we've
discovered so far and using this test we
asked how many of the patients at st.
Jude actually have Astro virus infection
so we looked at samples taken from our
pediatric oncology population between
2008 and 2018 and what we found was
quite surprising and that is that more
of our patients have an Astra virus
infection than they do other enteric
viruses including norovirus or people
like to think of it as the cruise-ship
virus this is a very common virus that
causes large outbreaks and populations
but yet in our population more of our
patients have a straw buyers they have
many different kinds of the virus
and it seems to increase as they go
through chemotherapy which makes sense
the more immunocompromised or the harder
it is for them to fight off infection
the more likely they are to become
infected the other problem with the
Astra virus in our particular population
or in other populations that can't fight
infections is that they can continue to
shed virus from very long periods of
time weeks months even years and this
gives the virus a lot of opportunity to
change and change very quickly the other
thing we notice in our population is
that when our patients have norovirus
they were more likely to have diarrhea
in contrast with Astro virus it may be
associated with diarrhea or it may not
they may have no symptoms whatsoever and
we're trying to understand why that is
happening and finally quite an
interesting finding in our patients is
that boys seem to shed virus longer than
girls and again this is something we
need to better understand and whether
there's a sex difference associated with
infection and disease so Astro viruses
can be very difficult to work with and
to really understand disease the reason
for that is there are no small animal
models for human Astro viruses and
that's typically the way that you try to
understand how a virus or bacteria
is causing disease further viruses are
parasites they have to get into a cell
in order to grow and very few of the
Astro viruses have cell culture systems
where we can actually grow them in the
laboratory and this is why we don't know
much about Astro virus disease however
we were fortunate in that we did find a
cell that would support human Astro
virus growth in the laboratory
and these are called keiko to their
human intestinal cancer actually cancer
cell lines that when we allow them to
grow they'll actually change and become
like an intestinal epithelial cell in
vivo so they differentiate and they do
support astra virus replication as you
can see by the replication kinetics
slide what was interesting is that when
we infected these Kate go-to sounds with
Astro virus the cells didn't die and
that is the typical way that viruses
caused disease and this was quite
intriguing
so we asked how big this virus be
causing disease if it's not killing the
sounds well to understand that we really
had to think about the intestinal
epithelial cells and what you can see in
the first image on the bottom left is
this is an actual picture of an
intestinal villi and you can see there's
a number of cells lining this villi and
they form these very very close
communications between each other and so
this is really important these cells in
the intestines have to be very closely
connected to protect the body from
whatever is in your gut and that will
include food it will include microbiome
bacteria other viruses and that is a
primary function of these epithelial
cells is to keep whatever is outside
your body from getting inside because if
you break these cells apart and disrupt
this barrier anything that's in your gut
women can get into your body so we
hypothesize or we ask could the Astro
virus even though it's not killing cells
could it be causing these cells to break
apart and we can measure this and test
this in the laboratory by growing these
cells on an insert where they'll form a
top and a bottom and that would be like
in your gut the top would be the inside
of your intestines and the bottom would
be inside of your body
and we can measure two things we can
infect the cells at the top and we can
measure we can put an ion or probe
through them and we can look at electric
flow and the tighter it is the tighter
that barrier is the other thing that we
can do is we can add fluorescent dyes
and we can look at how those dyes move
from the top to the bottom and using
these types of assays what we found is
that the human Astro virus actually
increases barrier permeability so what
happens is the cells start breaking
apart and it allows molecules to go from
the top into the bottom but this is in
cell culture we ask could this same
thing actually happen in the body well
let me go back what we found was very
curious at this these viruses could
cause these cells to come apart but what
was even more striking is that the virus
doesn't actually have to get into the
cell and infect it so on the outside of
the cell it has a protein called a
capsid that is all that's on the outside
of the Sun what we found is all you need
is that protein that capsid to interact
with the cells in order for these cells
to come apart and have this increased
barrier permeability so that's really
important we don't actually need
infectious virus we just need this outer
coat protein but this is very striking
because it would suggest that the virus
coat protein acts like a toxin and that
had not been shown before so we asked
could this be happening inside of an
animal in order to measure this we had
to use baby turkeys and a turkey Astra
virus why baby turkeys because they get
age-dependent
diarrhea from astra virus just like
people do so what we can do is we can
make this Astro virus turkey astra virus
coat protein all by itself and then we
can have the baby turkey swallow it and
what you can see
from these blue images is in the green
is where the viral protein or the cub
protein has gone in the south and then
what we do is it's it's very high-tech
we watch the turkeys go to the bathroom
and we came up with the rating score for
diarrhea and you can see there's one two
three four where we would consider for a
diarrhea and this is actually based on
what we see in humans so Google Bristol
stool chart and you can see that in
humans are seven different types and
it'll tell you what it will look like
the consistency and also what it tells
you about the health so using this
rating and knowing that this this viral
protein could get to the intestines we
asked what happens do the turkeys get
diarrhea and the answer is yes if you
look at the percent of birds with a
clinical score greater than three we can
see that this coat protein alone induces
them to have diarrhea in a concentration
dependent manner so we need very little
protein to have this happen so that
would suggest that this astro virus
capsid is a toxin how is it working well
as I told you what we saw in cell
culture is that it causes these
membranes to open up and breaks down
this barrier and we see exactly the same
thing in these baby turkeys so the top
bar graph is actually the epithelial
with the ions running through it to show
you the barrier and the bottom is
looking at those fluorescent dyes going
through the membrane so here's what
we're thinking you have this virus
getting to your intestines and most of
the time what it does is causes damage
to those cells and the cells die and you
can see from these purple images the
ones on the left are healthy intestines
the ones on the right are damaged we do
not have again anything like that
happening in the astra virus you
in animals in humans or in cell cultures
so what could be happening so Astro
virus is not killing the sound so how is
it breaking down this barrier well if
you look at how these cells are held
together in the intestines is what you
have is a cell one on the left the cell
2 on the right and they're held together
through a series of protein protein
interactions that make these cells
actually fit together and the top parts
are called tight junctions the next or
middle level are called adherence
junctions and then the bottom are called
desmosomes these are absolutely crucial
for forming this barrier and this is not
specific to an intestinal epithelial
cells you see this in all of your
epithelial cells as well as your
endothelial cells so what we think is
that the virus is actually unzipping or
pulling apart these cells so how is it
doing that and how do we know that so
here are images and that left-most are
uninfected cells and what we're looking
at is microscopy staining for these
individual cell cell proteins and you
were looking down on them as a
cross-section and you see this nice
cobblestone morphology and that is
actually the periphery of the cells
being held together in the top being
occluded 0 1 beta catenin and ecad hiren
so going from the top of the cell to the
bottom and what you can see is at
different times post infection these
cells actually are these proteins
actually come apart or move away from
the membrane and we lose them and this
is very evident at 24 hours if you
compare your MOC to 24 hours post
infection what we see is we've lost the
cell-cell contacts so basically that
virus is not killing the cell but it's
unzipping them and they're coming apart
like
but it's actually more complicated and
interesting than that it's completely
changing the sounds so these are
epithelial cells they are very important
for maintaining this barrier they have a
top in the bottom and what the astra
virus is doing is causing them to change
and actually become more migratory they
completely change shape these are the
kinds of changes in cells we see when
cancer happens and a cell goes from
being normal to cancerous it goes
through this epithelial to mesenchymal
transition and Astro virus is causing
the same sort of cellular change not
causing cancer just causing the cells to
change shape and how do we know that so
again the way that we can test that is
by first looking at microscopy and the
top panel is an epithelial protein eat
cat urine we're again you can see it's
at very high levels in MOC and it's gone
by 24 hours post infection in contrast
if we look for a protein that's only
found on these mesenchymal or more
migratory cells you can see in
uninfected cells there's nothing there
but after you've infected you can see
this increase in this protein in the
infected cells the other thing that
happens is that epithelial cells again
they have a top and a bottom meaning
they're polarized and this is again
important for their function and Astro
virus we lose that polarity so if you
look at the middle or the mock panel
what you can see are three different
colors red is a protein at the top of
the cell blue is the nucleus and green
is a protein that stains at the bottom
and sides of the South very clear
polarity now with an Astro virus
infection which is the next panel down
what you can see is that these layers
are messed up that's a very scientific
word I know but they are damaged you
no longer have the top at the top you
don't have things at the bottom so we
have changed the polarity of the sound
that's part of what makes it able to
start moving do we see this in vivo and
indeed we do we see the same thing when
we look in those baby turkeys so if you
look in their intestines for a protein
that should only be on the outside and
that would be in the one PBS and you can
see the green staining when we've added
that astro protein what you can see is
all that green staining protein has now
moved to the inside of the cell so we've
lost polarity in the intestine now your
intestine has got to maintain this
barrier it has to maintain polarity
because that's very important for
controlling fluids for controlling how
the gut responds and if any of this has
been damaged or is not working properly
you get what's considered leaky gut you
do not want leaky gut syndrome syndrome
there are a number of clinical
conditions associated with leaky gut or
increased intestinal permeability like
IBS Crohn's disease intestinal infection
but even things like alcoholism eczema
there's a number of syndromes and
diseases associated with having a leaky
gut so we have after virus going in the
coat protein causing the membrane is to
increase but yet we don't have leaky gut
syndrome why is that the reason is if
the virus has evolved a very clever way
of getting into the the cells it needs
growing and continuing to spread because
that's the goal of any viruses to get in
to replicate to make more virus come out
and infect the next person and cell and
what we found is that the Astra virus
actually is infecting goblet cells and
you can see that in the very first image
the red very red staining are infected
goblet cells and these are actually the
main producers of mucus and mucus is
absolutely crucial for gut health you
have to have mucus there it protects you
from pathogens it helps you maintain
your microbiome it helps you repair if
there's damage the astra virus is going
in and replicating in themselves and
this is very unique very few cells or
viruses have been shown to replicate in
a goblet cell they are only four to ten
percent of the population cells in your
entire gut very very low levels and what
we found is by actually being able to
isolate those very few cells and look at
what genes are being regulated well
here's a picture sorry this is a goblet
cell as you can see and here is a straw
virus within this goblet cells very
striking microscopy pictures so we got
these goblet cells and we're able to
isolate them and we asked what are the
genes look like so what is the virus
doing to those cells what we found it's
doing is actually increasing mucus
production any types of protein
associating with secreting that mucus as
well as a very protective molecule
called ido1 it is up regulating all of
these and we know they are absolutely
crucial in order to help the virus
replicate but also protect the host from
damage from the virus so to conclude we
have this very common enteric virus
leading cause of diarrhea especially
kids under the
to immunocompromised people and agent
adults but they're under diagnosed and
we don't understand much about disease
we do know that disease can range from
no symptoms at all to mild to severe
wasting diarrhea to systemic even fatal
brain infections but it doesn't appear
to work like other enteric viruses most
other viruses will go in they will
damage the cells in your intestines and
then your intestine won't work properly
in this case Astro virus outer coat
protein alone acts like a toxin it binds
to something on the cells that causes
cells to change lose their shape and
normal functions which could be bad but
when the virus gets in and begins
replicating it does control the cells
it's infecting to increase mucus
production and basically protect your
body and the host from getting leaky gut
syndrome so we're now asking either a
role for Astro virus and other gut
diseases and more importantly how do we
treat these if they can cause systemic
and even wasting especially in our
high-risk populations how are we gonna
treat this and treatment has
historically been oral rehydration
therapy but very recently we have found
an antiviral compound that will work
even after you're infected with Astro
virus which is very exciting and that is
a conclusion of my talk and of course I
have to thank everybody in my laboratory
because they do all the work everybody
at st. Jude the faculty people that help
us in the veterinary pathology Corps our
collaborators and our funding sources
and I thank you for participating and I
encourage you to ask questions and we
will respond by email share our passion
for both diarrhea and Astro viruses
thank you